Blood curdling scream and then a boom.
That's what the man
suing actress
Gwyneth Paltrow says happened
when she slammed into him on a ski slope.
Paltrow
describing a very different version
of events, saying he plowed into her
Veronica Miracle is OUTFRONT
this morning.
Actress and businesswoman Gwyneth Paltrow
back in court today for a civil trial
as the man suing her over a 2016
skiing accident took the stand
Something I've never heard of
the ski resort.
And that was a blood curdling scream.
It was like
somebody who was out of control
and gurney hit a tree
and was going to die.
Terry Sanderson insists
Paltrow skied into him on a beginner
ski slope at a Utah ski resort,
causing him severe brain damage
and other injuries.
But Paltrow vehemently denies this.
She's countersuing
Sanderson and claims he crashed into her.
I said,
You ski directly into my F-ing back.
I apologize for my bad language.
I'm like living another life now.
I can't ski anymore.
I was told
that if I did and had another crash,
that I could wind up full time.
Full time in a nursing home.
Animations produced by Paltrow's
legal team were shown to the court
to illustrate where Paltrow family
ski instructor Erik Christianson alleged
the parties were on the slope that day.
Christiansen,
who was with Paltrow's children
at the time of the accident,
testified about what he heard
and saw that the first he was apologizing
Then he also
made a statement about
she just appeared in front of me.
Christensen also
denied Sanderson's accusation
that he and Paltrow skied away
without offering any assistance
to Sanderson.
The whole time
I'm removing skis
and getting ready to help them
up, I'm asking, Are you okay?
He was firm.
He said yes.
Last week, Paltrow
described the crash
in an entirely different way,
even calling she
at first
thought she was being sexually assaulted.
I was skiing
and two skis came between my skis,
forcing my legs apart.
And then there was a body
pressing against me.
And there was a very strange
grunting noise.
I thought, Am I?
Is this a practical joke?
Is someone, like, doing
something perverted really?
And Paltrow's husband and two kids
were supposed to take the stand today,
but this trial is running behind.
In fact, the defense says
they may not have time
to get to Paltrow's family
and get them on the stand Aaron.
All right, Veronica, thank you very much.
Surprising.
We'll have to continue to follow that.